[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you've got two sides
the election couldn't possibly be
clearer you've got one side
that wants to tear the country down
wants to tear down the economic
principles that help build the country
you've got another side that wants to
support our founding principles
wants to support freedom wants to
support america
and you've got this man in the middle
president donald trump
who is here with the forces of
conservatism we are joined by one of the
great conservative voices
of our time a writer a filmmaker a
commentator
he does everything the one and only
dinesh d'souza dinesh thank you for
coming on
my pleasure looking forward to it so
dinesh
i have always enjoyed your movies i've
enjoyed going to the premieres of your
movies which are always extremely fun
here in hollywood you've got this movie
coming out trump card
and yet we're living in a time when no
one gets to go to the movies
yeah the theaters are you know in a
strange position in this age of cobit
and so i made the decision
to release the movie trump card uh to
video on demand so you can buy a
physical dvd
or you can watch it on a whole bunch of
platforms from itunes
to google to youtube many others through
a number of cable channels as well
so it's essentially a movie now that's
pay-per-view you can rent it or you can
buy it
and you can watch it at home and on any
device i mean i hope people watch it on
tv
because it was made for the big screen
uh you can still watch it on a computer
or phone but tv would definitely be the
best way
well i just watched it i highly
recommend everybody go watch it
as well you know there are so many
issues that we're thinking
about in this 24 7 news cycle i feel we
all have the attention span of
fruit flies and you've got the supreme
court nominations you've got
economic considerations you've got
foreign policy you've got all these
things
the movie much like the book that the
movie is based on focuses on
socialism socialism is the big issue aoc
has been pushing socialism the head of
the democrat party says that
this socialist is the future of the
democratic party
where does where does socialism fit
among all the other things we've got to
be weighing at the voting booth
i think socialism is the key it is the
destination
for the left and a good way to think
about it is you know there's some
internal debate is
biden a socialist uh elizabeth warren is
she a socialist light
here's a good way to think about it if
you think of the free market
at one end of the spectrum and socialism
which we can define loosely here as
state control of the economy uh at the
other end of the spectrum
ask yourself this question which
democrat is pulling in the free market
direction
answer none of them they're all pulling
in the socialist direction now
they differ from one another as push
differs from shove
it's a matter of degree but the bottom
line of it is they would all
move america toward the united states of
socialism and the movie explores what
does that actually mean what
is the type of socialism that they're
pushing is it a good thing
and if it's a bad thing how do we stop
it i know president trump has sort of
broken with some
republican and conservative orthodoxy at
least of the last few decades
particularly on free trade he's saying
we're getting bad trade deals we need
some trade protections if
if china's not going to play ball he's
kind of questioned some of these broader
trade agreements like nafta
so some left-wing critics will say well
trump is just pushing for a different
kind of socialism a different kind of
state control
what do they get wrong i mean what what
do do we have to embrace
totally free unfettered markets here to
oppose socialism or is there something
more specific
well i think the way that trump looks at
it and and i agree with him i actually
was on the other
the sort of libertarian side of the
fence the libertarians tend to look at
the world as a single market
and they tend to look at of the free
flow of people and the free flow of
products as being essential that's how
they define
if you will free trade and free movement
but i think trump realizes wait a minute
that's actually not the world we live in
the world we live in is divided into
countries
and just as we have individual interests
and business interests
we have an american interest and there's
a tendency for the libertarian to miss
that to miss that we are a team called
america
and it's the job of the president to
look out for that team it's not his job
to promote
global welfare it says he's elected to
promote the welfare of the people
who voted for him and the people also
voted against him but who belong to the
same
community so in the trade deal basically
trump is saying listen
if you have tariffs on the other side
the chinese side
the japanese side the french where they
won't let us sell our products over
there
why should we promiscuously say to them
listen you can openly sell your products
over here
let's have a deal in which we agree to
open up both sides and seems to me that
in the end if that's successful
uh that will promote more free trade and
not less
i think that's completely right i think
president trump has said that
as well he says he he likes trade he
likes when we can make some money he
likes when we can sell our goods
but you can't get ripped off you want
you want to be in a trade regime that
works for both people i i know sometimes
when when people hear economic arguments
their eyes glaze over there is there is
a reason that economics has been called
the dismal science is that what we're
talking about here with socialism is it
just some eggheads on spreadsheets
or is there is there more to it is there
a cultural
or even deeper component to socialism
that that threatens the country
yeah i think that um that's the right
way to think about socialism is as a
kind of
theft scheme and here's what i mean if
somebody were to say to you
go to your neighbor's house open his
refrigerator
and eat his stuff and then look around
and if you see nice things art on the
walls and so on take them
confiscated and bring it over to your
house and put it up on your wall now you
might say
most people would say that's horrible
why would i do that i'm not a thief
and if i did do it for whatever reason i
would feel terrible my conscience would
really
uh tell me i'm doing something very
wrong now
imagine if you're now approached by the
socialist who says michael
i've got news for you you know all that
nice stuff in your neighbor's house
it really belongs to you and if this
comes as a surprise
because he hasn't uh stolen it from you
don't worry his great great great
grandfather
actually had one fine day stole it from
your great great great grandfather so
it's really yours
but here's the wonderful news you don't
have to break into his house you don't
have to confiscate his stuff we
the state will do that for you and we'll
keep some of it for ourselves but we'll
give the rest of it to you
so you can see what's going on here
they're making you michael feel good
about being a thief
essentially socialism here is about the
annihilation of conscience
about eradicating that little voice in
our head that tells you don't do that
that's evil that's wrong they want to
snuff out that little voice
there's an example you gave a few years
ago maybe more than a few years ago now
that i
steal shamelessly i loved this
description
which is that you're walking down the
street and you see a bum
and you've got to know you've got a
sandwich or something and the bum is
hungry and so
you can you can give him your sandwich
and then that's a moral transaction
right he's grateful you've done an act
of charity that's great
and it's all well and good until you're
walking down the street
and barack obama shows up on a white
horse with a gun and he says you better
give that man your sandwich
and there no moral transaction has taken
place
the bum feels entitled i feel resentful
and obama robbed me at gunpoint
that that moral calculation has totally
been been shifted from what otherwise
would be a moral and charitable act
that's absolutely right essentially what
happens is that socialism strips the
virtue
entirely out of the transaction even
though one could say hey the outcome is
the same in both cases the guy ended up
with a
sandwich or with half your sandwich but
the fact that it was in one case
compelled by force
makes it not a good deed on your part uh
no obligation or even gratitude on his
part
uh and makes the state a kind of corrupt
colluder with what is ultimately a form
of extortion
do you think dinesh i know that for
decades particularly after william f
buckley jr and
the post-war conservative movement there
was this fusion
of libertarians who were very interested
in the economic issues
and of social conservatives and
traditionalists who were more interested
in
i don't know god and guns and you know
all sorts of cultural matters
and they obviously had a common enemy in
the soviet union which was both
collectivist
and atheist but in recent years that has
frayed a little bit
i i even have to say as someone who i
consider myself very traditional
culturally conservative i've worried
that there is
a kind of softening on socialism that
has gone on in some parts of the
conservative movement
do you see that happening if so do you
how do you think we can
rectify that well i think there's there
is a remaking of the parties to some
degree i mean first of all it's because
the situation is completely different
the old battle was a cold war against a
foreign opponent and so
the the cold war defined if you will the
two political camps
and now it's i call it in the movie the
new one trump card i call it a cold
civil war
so we're dealing with a domestic
opponent and so
naturally the dividing lines are going
to be somewhat different
the republican party really used to be
the party of the rich that wasn't just
the left caricature but basically rich
people voted for the republicans
but you'll notice that's no longer true
the richest people in this country
support the democrats big corporations
not only give money to the democratic
party they give money to antifa and
black lives
lives matter so what i'm finding is the
republican party is becoming the party
of the middle class and the working
class and that's a massive shift because
the working class
white and black was essentially the the
bedrock of the fdr coalition that was
the backbone of the democratic party
and yet if you find a working-class guy
today chances are much better you'll
find him not at the
aclu or at the union meeting you're
gonna more likely find him in the trump
rally
right he's not gonna be wearing some
sort of silly
uh coexist sign on his shirt or
something
he's probably more likely to be wearing
a maga hat but then this this raises
this point
that the left always brings up they say
these rubes these deplorables these
bitter clingers
they're so stupid that they're voting
against their own interests because
look the left and the socialists they're
willing to give them a bunch of free
stuff so
are these people just just absolute
maniacs for rejecting that
and embracing a more traditional and
conservative message
the genius of trump i think is that he
has appealed to these people both on
their economic
and their cultural interests remember
for years republicans would incense
turn to the working class and say listen
we know you don't agree with us on
economic issues
but on the other hand you're pro-life
aren't you so let's you let's let that
trump if you will your economic concerns
trump made an all-out appeal to these
people and said listen
who has stripped away your jobs by and
large what's happened is that's the
product
of a certain kind of blind globalization
which we have not been attentive
to our national interest and the reason
that journalists and lawyers and a lot
of the dc types never cared about this
is they don't care about you
they don't care about your life your
livelihood your communities your schools
uh drug problems in your communities
well i do i do
so the bottom line of it is yes it's
true that a working-class guy can say
listen i don't have a job but no worries
i can sit on my couch forever and
collect a check from the democrats
they'll give me universal basic income
so i can be a lifelong drone
in fact that's what they want you to be
um and
then they want to create perhaps the
kind of intergenerational dependency in
other words they want to do what white
people what to white people what they've
already done basically to the black
community
i think the good news is that trump is
saying to whites and blacks listen
you can break out from this dependency
you can be a free american again and a
free american with a real job
and so that's where i think the populist
republican party is
and i really don't see any future in
turning back
i i agree entirely and i've noticed
something in recent days
that president trump is calling
attention to a very specific issue
that a lot of people didn't think he
would call attention to that is the
academy higher education specifically
critical theory and sort of various
leftist ideologies that have permeated
the academy
that in many ways launched you
into the national discussion with one of
your great books which i
highly recommend people read as well
illiberal education
you you were sounding the alarm bell on
on this kind of
rot that was going on in the american
mind decades ago
and it would seem that if the situation
that you were describing has followed
the course
that you predicted it's gotten so much
worse
is there hope for a country that
is constantly educating its students and
its future generations
to hate itself
no um and i think the big difference
between now and then when i wrote a
liberal education
and i described some of the insanity
that was going on on the campus
and by the way it was not as bad as it
is now a lot of people off campus
leftists would say come on dinesh you're
exaggerating your book is a collection
of anecdotes
you're overstating the problem the
campus isn't really a lunatic asylum
uh and my view is listen it is a bit of
an asylum but
fortunately it is walled off from the
rest of society fortunately in a sense
people when they go off to college
they go on to a kind of a a special kind
of community with its own rules
but now i think what's happened is that
not only have the campuses become
crazier
but the craziness has metastasized into
the larger culture you could almost say
that academia is the theory
and antifa is the practice because if
you believe your country is awful
and it wasn't just um the slave owners
and the confederates but it's
abraham lincoln is awful and george
washington is awful and frederick
douglass the great
abolitionist is awful pretty soon
they'll be saying martin luther king is
awful
and so the idea here is to pull down
their statues and desecrate their legacy
these are the doctrines that have been
taught in academia for a long time but
they've been picked up now by hollywood
and the media
and blasted into the larger culture so
right now essentially the campuses
ideology has become the ideology of the
left
nationwide do you have i'm just looking
for some
glimmer of hope even as we see our
country on fire all around us
do you think that the the shutdown of
the campuses
because of the covid lockdowns do you
think that that will give us a chance
to sort of break this mania that has
overtaken american education or
is that just a mirage is is the academy
going to
continue its liberal uh liberal project
regardless i think so it will continue
that project i don't think that we can
reasonably expect to take back you know
300 or 400 campuses that's not going to
happen the only way it's going to happen
in my opinion
is if we are we meaning our side invents
the academic iphone if we can deliver
high quality world-class academic and
educational services
at a fraction of the price that would be
essentially turning all of academia into
a rotary phone it'd be obsolete
they'd have the buildings they would
hang around for a while but they
wouldn't hang around all that long
because there's just a better product on
the market um in hollywood i'm trying to
not only make feature films i've
released my first feature film called
infidel and theaters now
why because i wanted to make not just a
christian movie or a conservative movie
but a mainstream political thriller
with jim caviezel in the lead so i can
compete with big hollywood movies like
tennant or the russell crowe movie and
this shows us that we don't just
criticize the left
but we challenge them and defeat them we
beat their business model and we can
show that whatever they can do
we can do better i think you're a great
example
of for people who say oh it's just a
lost cause there's no way we can win in
hollywood there's no way
that we can win in these spaces that are
now dominated by the left
your movies have been extraordinarily
successful and they've done very very
well this is what
is this your fifth movie now or
well it's my fifth and i also have the
feature film so i've got trump card as
my fifth documentary now that's not in
the theater i should let people know
that's available on video on demand and
if you go trumpcardthemovie.com
you can buy it from walmart or target
and dvd or you can watch it on a whole
bunch of platforms from google to
youtube to itunes apple itunes
and so on uh so yes i think that look
it's harder for our side because if
you're michael moore or oliver stone you
want to make a movie you go to a studio
they go here's 10 million dollars here's
20 million dollars and then once you
make the movie
hey you're on the today show hey you're
on the view hey you're on this hey
you're on that for us
we got to do the legal work we got to
put the business plan together we got to
raise the money we got to make the movie
and then we've got to market it with
absolutely no help from these cultural
elites
so i don't count on them i don't rely on
them but bottom line of it is you have
to have this
broad ensemble of skills from that are
financial skills but also creative
skills and marketing skills
to be able to pull it off and by the way
you need courage because sometimes for
instance if you were to make a movie
critical of barack obama then the
bureaucracy of the federal government
might become weaponized against you
to selectively punish you i'm just a
totally hypothetical example obviously
but that well not not to mention these
guys are now on the board at netflix and
so they have a lot of influence in the
in the even the market institutions that
are instrumental in
promoting movies fortunately again our
movies are done well
so we have a good way of getting them
out there and distributing them well
and i'm very happy about that but long
term we've got to do a lot more of this
and the same thing with media
the left just has a much wider media
reach than we do
so ultimately i don't see how we can win
long term if we don't
create some important beach heads and
this isn't just about this election
because it affects every election
right and in the movie in trumpcard you
you describe us
presently as in a cold civil war the
nice thing about
the last cold war is that it never got
all that hot you know there were there
were hot spots here and there but there
was a peaceful
conclusion to it do you do you foresee a
peaceful conclusion to this or do you
see america
literally breaking apart no i i think it
i think we can have a peaceful
conclusion it's going to require really
both sides but mostly their side to come
to their senses
now i predict if trump wins they will go
crazier in the short term and we have to
sort of be ready for that
but in the long term it's a very good
thing because the only thing that will
stop them is holding them
accountable it's kind of like if an
antifa guy breaks a window and nobody
says anything he'll break all the
windows in the neighborhood he'll he
defines success
uh as how many windows are broken and
his aggression is tempted
by our passivity so the more you hold
them accountable
suddenly some antifa guy you know he he
beats somebody up he gets two years in
prison his friends go oh wow this is
probably not a good idea so then they
all go home so
this is how you put the stuff in check
the problem that happened in 1860 was it
got out of hand
uh this that was a by the way that was a
civil war that was 40 years brewing
and therefore once it was unleashed it
was unleashed at gale force
i hope we can avert that kind of outcome
here i think we can
but to do that we have to hold the left
accountable and we have to all live by
the same rules
right i do sadly see some parallels now
as we talk about
the democrats trying to add new states
to the union and how that will upset the
balance of power the talk of the balance
of power on the court
does have some some overtones of the
1850s unfortunately so i don't think
it's hyperbolic
to say that we're in a very precarious
place as a country
before i let you go i do have to ask the
kind of pressing
political predictions do you have any
thoughts on what's going to happen
november 3rd or in any of the days
afterward
i have a good feeling about it i trust
my own instincts is i don't go so much
by the polls now the polls do give me
pause
because we should always um not confuse
what we
want to happen with what is going to
happen i remember in 2012 when i would
tell people i think romney is going to
lose they say
what i thought you were a conservative i
thought you were a republican i go i am
i'm voting for romney
but i'm telling you what i think is
going to happen not what i want to
happen
but i think the left has the same
disease they're so desperate for trump
to be defeated that they massage the
polls they oversample the democrats they
ask questions in a leading way so i
wouldn't be surprised if the polls
grossly understand trump's support
and he pulls off another big nasty
surprise for them in november
that would be a wonderful trump card uh
in november 4th or
in the long litigation that is no doubt
to follow that would be pretty fun
as well yes it will i think
the bottom line here is that the left
knows that we are the party of the nice
guys and they take advantage of it
this is why they want to pack the court
they're convinced that even if we come
to power we won't pack the court on our
side
they can knock down our monuments
they're confident that we won't knock
down
their monuments they can use the deep
state against us they know that even if
we controlled all the branches of
government we wouldn't dream of using
the deep state against them
so the bottom line i'm trying to say is
that because republicans are seen as
nice guys
the left takes advantage of our
innocence if you will our virtue
in order to bend the rules on their side
in the full confidence that it won't be
done to them
i think that is a an astute diagnosis i
think that probably is what brought us
president trump in the first place you
know you feed up a bunch of nice guys
and uh eventually if the left won't
relent you need a tough guy to go in
there and clean house
we can all hope that he continues to
clean house after uh november 3rd
in the meantime highly recommend
everyone goes out watches trump card
it's not in the theaters you know the
theaters
are in kind of mayhem right now with the
lockdowns so you got to get it
what are the streaming platforms dinesh
so go to trumpcardthemovie.com you can
buy the dvd from target or walmart
uh and you can watch it on amazon itunes
by download or google
or fandango there's a whole bunch of
platforms you can generally get it
through your cable platforms as well
trumpcardthemovie.com that's where you
can go get it for now we know big tech
wants to uh kick us all off so
for now you can go get it uh would we
definitely recommend you do it dinesh
thank you as always
great to talk to you and we will we will
keep our fingers crossed
through the movie i'm i'm sure it will
do very well and then through november
3rd to see if we can
hold on to this country of ours for a
little while longer for sure
thank you very much all right
[Music]
you